[Musique]
pour ce nouveau volet patrimoine je vous
emmène au coeur de l'osmothèque un
conservatoire international de parfum
est inaugurée par jean pierre léaud avec
un groupe de parfumeurs passionnés ce
lieu unique au monde est implantée à
versailles dans les locaux de l'issic
cas anne-cécile prompt directrice
déléguée de l'osmothèque et isabelle
chassot présidente du comité
scientifique et nous ont donné rendez
vous pour une visite sur mesure c'est
parti
[Musique]
les trois grandes missions de
l'osmothèque sont la plus importante la
préservation de ce patrimoine donc ça
c'est la collection de parfums de
l'osmothèque ensuite nous avons une
partie médiation culturelle donc nous
transmettons nous faisons connaître nous
faisons découvrir ou redécouvrir les
trésors et les chefs-d'oeuvre du
patrimoine de la parfumerie et enfin
nous avons un programme de recherche qui
nous permet de faire avancer la
connaissance que l'on a de l'histoire du
parfum c'est un lieu on retrouve
l'émotion on a connu avec certains
parfums porté par des gens qu'on a aimé
le parfum est un art donc nous
conservons une histoire de cet art à
travers les parfums essais on vient à le
smau tech sentir des parfums comme on va
dans un musée voir des tableaux ou des
sculptures c'est tout à fait la même
démarche
[Musique]
le fruit défendu doubi gants ou encore
crêpe de chine de coty ici on peut
retrouver près de 850 parfums a disparu
et parmi eux des trésors du passé
on a par exemple parfum royal qui datent
du premier siècle après jésus-christ en
tout cas on la refait à partir d'une
recette de pline l'ancien qui est donc
au 1er siècle après jésus-christ on a
fait une interprétation c'est une
exception dans la collection de
l'osmothèque et ça vous donne une idée
de ce que pouvait sentir un romain sans
doute d'une classe aisée de cette époque
là c'est un parfum
extrêmement puissant qui contient
beaucoup de cannelle qui contient 27
ingrédients et qui
est très différent de ce qu'on pouvait
de ce qu'on peut sentir actuellement
dans une on a pas aussi par exemple
l'eau de la reine de hongrie qui
date soit disant du 14e siècle qui est
sans doute la recette est sans doute un
peu plus ancienne mais c'est en tout cas
un des premiers parfums fait avec de
l'alcool
[Musique]
oh
plus de cinq mille parfums sont
conservés ici et justement on va aller
découvrir ces conditions de conservation
dans la cave un endroit inaccessible au
public
donc ici nous conservons les parfums
dans des
à l'abri de trois ennemis qui sont la
lumière donc nous mettons les parfums
dans des flacons en verre sombre anti-uv
les variations de température donc nous
les conservons toute l'année à 12 degrés
pour éviter les effets thermiques et
nous les protégeons aussi de l'oxygène
qui est un ennemi du parfum et donc pour
cela nous mettons à chaque fois que nous
prélevons dans une dans un flacon que
nous appelons flacon mer un gaz plus
lourd que l'air qui vient assurer une
sorte de couche de protection
[Musique]
montrez ce parfum qui fait qui a fêté
ses 100 ans donc là on est sur une
version d'émeraude reposer par
un os noter qu'air pour que nous
puissions encore aujourd'hui 100 ans
après sentir ce parfum tels que françois
coty l'a rêvé et la proposer aux femmes
en 1921 le site est accessible sur
rendez-vous ou via des découverte
olfactive plus d'informations sur le
site de l'osmothèque
[Musique]